die nachwehen von der krawalle von der
nacht der schande in stuttgart horst
seehofer thomas strobl und
ministerpräsident winfried kretschmann
schauten sich dort heute vor ort um wie
sehen sie hier am mittag in stuttgart
man sieht noch immer letzte anzeichen
von dem was passiert ist polizeiautos
mit eingeschlagenen scheiben unter
anderem ja mittlerweile weiß man auch
mehr über die täter sie müssen sich wie
heute wie gerade schon gesagt jetzt vor
dem haftrichter verantworten
barfuß mit hand und fuß stellen mit
mundschutz und haube
so schläft heute einer der
festgenommenen randalierer von stuttgart
zum haftrichter
doch wer sind die täter der gewalt nacht
die polizei spricht vor allem von
jugendlichen einem 16 jährigen wird nun
versuchte totschlag vorgeworfen er soll
einen am boden liegenden studenten
gezielt auf den kopf getreten haben so
die staatsanwaltschaft vor zwei stunden
auslöser der randale angeblich die
drogenkontrolle eines 17-jährigen mit
dem kontrollierten solidarisierten sich
laut der polizei sofort bis zu 500
personen die mit steinen und flaschen
gegen die beamten vor gingen insgesamt
randalieren bis zu 500 junge menschen in
der stuttgarter innenstadt bilanz der
fünfstündigen randale 24 vorläufige
festnahmen 19 verletzte polizisten 40
beschädigte oder geplünderte läden und
zwölf demolierten polizeifahrzeuge
diese aufnahme schockte dabei besonders
ein polizeibeamter wird während einer
festnahme plötzlich von einem
randalierer von hinten umgetreten mit
voller wucht und mit anlauf bild hat nun
exklusiv mit diesen beamten gesprochen
sein name ulrich s 51 jahre alt
polizeihauptkommissar
ich habe halt meinen job gemacht und das
gehört dazu wir waren mit knapp 300
kollegen im einsatz und allen kollegen
ging es so wie mir ich war halt jetzt
derjenige der mit foto in die medien kam
aber andere kollegen hatten ähnliche
situationen so was wie das jetzt in
stuttgart das haben wir noch nie erlebt